I'd like to tell you about a problem
that's very famous in some circles I've
seen it used as like an interview
question for uh admissions tests but
I've also seen just as a puzzle I would
like you to imagine Brady there are 100
light switches in front of you at the
moment they're all off the first person
coming along and turns them all on
the second person turns every second
light switch off
the third person deals with every third
light switch
in that they don't just turn them on or
off if they're on they'll turn them off
and if they're off they'll turn them on
and the fourth person deals with every
fourth light switch the fifth person
deals with every fifth light switch I
suspect you have the pattern and that
continues for a hundred people that's
the setup the question which probably
you've already arrived at what happens
at the end which light switches are on
when 100 people have done this thing so
the hundredth person just comes on and
changes the state of the 100th switch
I've said this before Brady you're a
pleasure to work with you're already
thinking of the extremes of the problem
and it's a really good approach to
anything you're not sure about you sort
of jump to the extreme thing the 100th
person is going to deal with every 100th
flight switch which in this particular
sample is just the last one in our lot
after a moment's thought you might
realize that anyone beyond the 50th
switch
is only going to have to deal with one
switch because they're sort of the next
multiple is is out of our sample
but that we've done the setup so as ever
in a good puzzle if you weren't actually
going to think about it now is a good
time which light switches are on after
100 people have been through
do you have any thoughts about the sort
of numbers we're going to have to talk
about in this problem
obviously the further we go the early
lights are frozen in time they're not
going to get changed anymore so after
the fourth person's been through are you
what are you saying with the first four
lights yeah they're not going to change
again yeah if you could sort out what
happens for the first 10 and get a
picture of what's left on then maybe you
get a clue about what's happening so I
want to show you some of the answer
spoiler coming here's the situation all
the lights are on now first person's
gone in and turned all the lights on so
100 lights on and person two comes in
and turns every other light off because
they were all on just because it gets
harder to see what happens next I'll do
the third person and this pattern
emerges which is maybe not too difficult
to arrive after thought but then as soon
as you put the fourth person in
me personally I feel slightly surprised
about the pan and I didn't expect sort
of a five and then a double Gap and then
a single Gap and
and after that the pattern maybe is very
hard to predict and we've got to go all
through 100 here so that's my first
spoiler but what you said is nice
because you know that after the first
four people have gone through those four
are not gonna change again so I'm gonna
claim that maybe number one number four
are on if I go one more hence the last
spoiler I'm gonna get before you give it
away five has gone off and five is never
going to change again but the pattern
Now is really even quite hard to spot I
think if you look long enough you can
see something repeating but the repeat
the pattern is getting longer each time
and I sort of dread to try and predict
what happens by this method if I go much
further so we should maybe generalize
and figure out what is going to make a
light switch turn on or off and how many
times and is it going to be off or on by
the end every time I've pose this
problem with people and I'm curious to
know if you're the same or if anyone
watching is the same people have
mentioned a certain type of number to me
that seems to be important which are
prime numbers
do they feel like they have any bearing
on this I wouldn't have thought so well
the interesting thing about it is that
if a number is Switched it's because the
person going in has their their number
is a factor of that number so in that
sense factors or devices are going to be
important here it's a slightly dead end
here so if you imagine a prime like at
the number five we've already
established on my little example here
number five is often it's never getting
changed again so maybe we could
conjecture that primes are going to be
off and indeed if you look at earlier
primes two and three are indeed off and
the rest we're not sure about but we
could for example think of the number
seven let me just write down a fact you
know about seven those are the factors
of seven because its primary only has
two factors if it only has two factors
only two people are going to switch that
switch
first person
and the seventh person
therefore I think it's not a million
miles away for anyone to link to the
conclusion that it will be off because
it's been turned off on by the first
person and then off by the seventh in
fact any Prime is going to do that
because it only gets touched twice so
primes are always off yes but if we look
at the number six for example and I
could I could do it on the demo but
maybe it's easier to think about how we
could do it I'm going to write this down
who's going to uh who's going to hit
number six well
this is obvious but I can also write it
in another way
and I think what I've kind of pointed
out the long way around is that six has
four factors or four devices I'm going
to ask you to make the leap if if it's
going to get hit by person one because
that's a factor person two person three
and person six what will happen by the
end for number six so one turns it on
two turns it off yeah three turns are on
yep six turns off yeah so if it has an
even number of factors it ends up off if
it has an even number of divisors yeah
it ends up off I think you just said the
same thing twice using two different
words that people use for the same thing
devices factors I think maybe uh us and
UK differ divide in fact about how they
uh they choose but factors and devices I
mean the numbers that divide exactly
into another and you're right six ends
up off and if you want to check let's do
the uh experiment six person's gone in
number six is off and our conjecture so
far that six should be off is correct
and you made it even more General an
even number of factors and the lag will
be off by the end okay let me give you
another bonus fact which maybe is
obvious factors come in pairs right
so does every number have an even number
of
no it doesn't because we see that four
is on hang on
I'm really glad you've said the word
hang on here this should be the
mathematical moment because factors come
in pairs oh but they can be duplicate
pairs when would that happen like two
times two four so if I wrote down four
all right I could write it down as one
times four I could also write it as two
times two but the duplication here has
meant they're actually only three
factors good we're making progress we've
established why I think number four is
left on you're doing so well so far what
would be the next light that stays on a
square number do you want to pick your
favorite Square that's not been done
well nine nine is the next one should we
check it yeah I mean having a an ability
to experiment like this by the way is
underrated I think in mathematics but a
lot of people think you should be doing
on your head but not just experimenting
and testing conjectures is nice so let's
do it seven
seven is off eight and nine is already
off so when I put the ninth person in lo
and behold nine is on
and if we check it right nine you can
write it as one times nine how else can
you write it well it's not two times
anything but it is three times three and
that's it in fact if you're checking
factors you only ever need to check up
to the square root of a number before
you should probably stop wasting your
time and checking anymore and how many
factors well
one two three conjecture so far
well what is looking good squares odd
numbers numbers with an odd number of
factors anything that has a times itself
unless that does it twice
unless it has two two numbers well we
already you've kind of talked yourself
into the square numbers are apparently
going to be on because of the
duplication yeah but now you're worried
about whether that happens twice if it's
going to change it so maybe we should
try an example
can you think of it a square of a square
I'm asking you to do so much while
you're holding the camera yeah uh four
is square and you could Square Four to
get uh still a relatively low number
uh four times four so we should check
16. let's check 16. do you want to try
on paper before we actually yeah so 16.
one times sixteen nice Brady keep going
four times four two times eight nice
because if we if we go up in a sort of
nice pan window when we've got them all
three times I don't think is going to
work and four times four first things
first is it a square yes it's got this
duplicated so were you expecting to see
more here
no but I don't know whether the fact
that you can expand that to two times
two times two means anything probably
not well what we should be doing here is
bearing in mind something which sounds
important called the fundamental theorem
of arithmetic the fundamental Theory
arithmetic says that every number has a
unique prime factor decomposition so
we're writing down factors not prime
factors and there's more than one way of
writing them down which is kind of what
we're using but every number has a
unique way of writing it in primes and
you probably know that and maybe that's
going to help us because that's kind of
to do with what you're pointing out here
that you could expand the eight into two
times two times two so let's just do the
prime factor decomposition of 16. uh
it's just 2 to the four if you break all
these down to primes you just left with
that nine is three squared if we jump
say to let's do 24 not a square number
let's see what it decomposes as well
let's just do the old-fashioned way one
times 24 2 times 12 3 times 8 4 times 6
and then we're done interestingly
they're coming in pair still and if you
write it as a prime factor decomposition
it's going to be two
times 12 but 12 is 2 times 6 and 62
times 3 so it's that and I would write
it as 2 cubed times three so it's worth
I think whenever you're working with a
problem that has factors involved noting
the difference between factors or
devices and prime factors
and I think you've already got to the
heart of this and I guarantee some
people are watching this video they're
like we've got there straight away
because if you spot the one thing which
you have already spotted this becomes a
number Theory question and you said it
the numbers with an odd number of
factors are going to be on
and the ones with an even number are
going to be off so it becomes which
numbers have an odd number of factors
we've already established by
experimenting the squares appear to but
is only them
and do some squares not well we've
checked the 16. let me give one spoiler
the only numbers
that have an odd number of factors are
the squares
which I think we should dive into to
finish this video but if that's true can
you predict what lights are going to be
on at the end of our story well we did 2
squared 3 squared 4 squared 25
36. should we just animated you see yeah
I mean there's two things to watch out
for which one's turn on by the end and
the patterns we get along the way which
uh even if you've done this problem
before maybe you haven't seen this
before and it's quite it's quite
pleasing so let's just animate and see
how that goes 16 25 is on 36 is on
49's looking good Brady 64.
and 100. congratulations even though I
don't think you said it you told me the
equivalent statement which is the
numbers with an odd number of factors
are on and this surprises some people
the square numbers I would never have
guessed that at the start no and a lot
of people immediately say this problem
they're like oh it's gonna be to do with
the primes which is why I mentioned that
earlier which I think is why people like
it as an interview star question because
it has that slightly unexpected
squares are something to do with factors
but they are and it's quite a nice
profound number Theory fact that I
haven't proved yet it is only the
squares that have an odd number of
factors
and maybe we should prove that are you
up for that yeah because I want to
figure out whether or not this was a
complete red herring the fundamental
theorem of yeah well now we've
established that because of the on and
off nature it's you'd need an odd number
of facts of fit to stay on and crucially
all factors come in pairs because that's
what factors do and you spotted The
crucial thing is that that only breaks
down when you have a duplication that's
where the count changes but let's prove
it a little bit more formally and we're
trying to give us our space down here do
you want more paper I don't think we
need more paper breeding all right let's
do it with 24 as an example so 24 is 2
cubed times three that's its prime
decomposition and that's almost always a
good place to start let me point out how
you'd figure from that how to count the
factors now we've done it and there
aren't very many but if this was a huge
number I don't think I'd want to listen
by hand so if this is its prime factor
decomposition a factor must be some
subset of numbers in that otherwise it
wouldn't multiply it together so I could
for example pull out two a two is in
there agreed I could pull out two of the
twos and I could go up to three of the
twos but if I tried to put four twos
it's not in here so it's not a subset
and I could pull out a two with a three
or I could pull out the three on its own
and then have we done them all one two
three four five I think there should be
a few more factors what have I missed
well I could pull out 2 squared with the
three I could put out 2 cubed with the
three
and there's got to be a better way to
count this so what I've I've got two
times three two squared with three two Q
times a three that's the full one what
have I missed there should be eight I'm
thinking there are eight over here and
I'm wondering if it's obvious so the the
number is what about the number itself
and one well that's that's there the
number itself but you're right the one
is the Hard One to spot because it's
kind of the weird subset of this
and so here's what's happening I'm
choosing some of the numbers in the list
to make a factor
and actually the only way I can do it is
is controlled by the power here there's
actually a power one here that's kind of
invisible
and I can go I could do any of the
numbers up to three including zero
so to make this a bit more obvious I
could have two to the zero I could have
two to the one I could have two to the
two and I can have two to three in the
mix and I can have three to the zero or
three to the one that makes and any
combination gives me one of the factors
so that's it it's just how many options
have I have for that which is always
going to be one more than that number
and how many options do I have for that
so if we're going to generalize
I'd like a piece of paper
told you now we've got an appropriately
fresh piece of paper to generalize on
I'm going to write down uh for some
number n
you can always write it as a product
primes let's call them P1 and P2 and P3
and so on what should we go up to p k
are you happy with that so far and to
condense the notation like some of these
problems might be the same so let's you
can put them as a power so let's call
this uh C1 C2 and these are the indices
of the powers and CK that every number
can be written like that some of these
don't exist but we just pointed out on
the previous page that it's the number
of options you have for each prime that
controls it so we had three there before
but we had four options for the two
let's do the zero to the one two the two
two the three so c one plus one options
so how many that prompt to include but
then completely separately there's the
options here so you can multiply like
whatever you do there you can do a
different option here so I've got C2
plus one C3 plus one all the way to C K
plus one and the number of factors is
well defined as this it's the product of
the powers of the prime factors plus one
which means we are almost within grasp
of proving your conjecture earlier which
is that it's only the squares which have
an odd number so the square numbers will
have one integer which multiplies by
itself to give you that number that's
the definition of a square which means
when you look at its prime factors they
will always come in duplicates that
there will always be a prime squared or
to the power of four it will be an even
power otherwise you couldn't split it in
half
which means all of these numbers
are even in a square
which means if you add one to them all
for a square number
or odd all of these
will be odd
which means the product a little more
is odd
and we can also see kind of the reverse
if any one of them
was odd originally at the top then
adding one to it would make it even and
we would actually just get an even
number here which is what you normally
get an even number of factors come in
pairs only takes one of them to break it
because a product of anything with an
even number is also even the only time
they end up all odd is if you had a
square to start with and we're done the
answer to the puzzle of the light
switches is it's the squares that stay
on there are lots of other questions you
could ask if you want to explore which
is how many times does each switch get
switched and that is just its number of
factors uh do some get switched which
light switch is going to break first if
you repeatedly have fun with this and
that's less obvious because it's asking
which numbers have lots of factors and I
don't think we have a very good
intuition about this we know the primes
don't have many factors
for some factors some numbers have lots
of factors so actually this uh this
puzzle hinges on a really important
sequence called Tau or Sigma is
important enough to have a name which is
the number of devices of a number and if
you look it up on the online
encyclopedia of integer sequences it has
the name a00005
it's very early the naming of the
integer sequences or the labeling I
don't quite understand but it however
you name it you've got to attach
importance to the first ones
even though the first one is something
to do with groups feels profound and the
rest of them I'm not quite sure I
recognized however number five is the
sequence of the numbers of divisors of a
number and if you look at the ones that
have high number of devices it's numbers
like 60 60 is the first one to have 12
factors which we could check by doing
this if you wanted to uh so six is 60
the switch that gets switched the most
in the first hundred there are others
with 12 factors but it's the first one
to get switched 12 times
um it's what they call a highly
composite number it's the first time
that its number of factors beats all the
ones before it
um and I looked briefly up to this and
if you carried on to say 200 light
switches the number 180 gets knobbled
more than often than the others and you
start to recognize those numbers as the
ones we use to divide things which are
helpful to have fractions for like
portions of a circle you won't be
surprised to know that another highly
composite number is 360. so we measure
time in 60s we measure angles in 360s
it's partly because of the number of
factors here I'm glad you found a route
to the the number the problem here which
is only the square numbers have an odd
number of factors and that feels like a
pleasing outcome to actually contrast
puzzle
if you enjoyed that video well you're
going to love all the courses quizzes
and puzzles on brilliant
here's the leaning tower of Lira also
known as the block stacking problem it's
part of their superb calculus in a
nutshell course
it's great and here's where brilliant
really shines it's super interactive you
can really get Hands-On with this stuff
there are thousands of lessons and
courses on brilliant and new ones are
being added all the time from beginner
to advanced mathematics computer science
AI neural networks this is a treat
Beyond Compare for all level of learners
to check out brilliant yourself maybe
give it as a gift for the Learner in
your life go to brilliant.org number
file that URL which is also in the
description can get you a discount on
their premium subscription and there's
also a 30-day free trial thanks
brilliant for supporting numberfile and
making such cool stuff on the internet
[Music]